the gyro can experience you know I had
Bernie Sanders on yesterday and who that
guy is running for something it kind of
looks like my dad and I've briefly
looked into the comments of one of the
posts and so many [ __ ] people are so
goddamn toxic yeah they're just battling
it out left and right and
misrepresenting his position miss Rep
someone's calling me and all right white
supremacist white nationalist like what
in the [ __ ] that's so I sent a t-shirt
so this has someone said that I had some
what what is it's storm front or
something like that what is that white
supremacist Paige storm front of
something they said I had the founder of
Stormfront on my part the [ __ ] are you
talking about you just Mary Oh probably
no I'm so proud of those guys yeah I had
Gavin McGinnis Gavin who is the founder
of the problem yeah I had him on before
but I had him on before there was a
brown boys I didn't even know what the
[ __ ] yeah but also why can't you talk to
her son I asked him about it and I was
critical I was criticizing him I was
like you can't just claim you're gonna
have violence with people it's it's so
[ __ ] dumb and then all the proud boys
[ __ ] that happened with violence came
far after that but people are like
blaming me for having him on I don't
even know what the [ __ ] it is he's the
co-founder of ice that's just it's also
interesting don't you want to hear the
other side like don't want to hear
everyone's opinions and everyone's
thoughts don't you want to try to
understand and come to a common ground
don't you want to realize like I'm not
religious really or anything but it's
like we are all God's children like
there's missing this whole thing it's
this fight against each other yes but no
okay the problem is there's a lot of
these people that do go on shows and try
to reinvent themselves disingenuous way
and they try to whitewash what they're
doing whitewash their past and to that
point I mean the idea is that you're
helping them recruit people okay before
he was on my podcast though there was no
work there was no people for him to
recruit to the people need to understand
like he wasn't there was nothing like I
had him on because he was this guy was
funny and he used to do a lot of
interesting video
he [ __ ] up when he started that group
and he [ __ ] up when he was calling for
violence and telling people to choke a
[ __ ] and punch people and grab these
people and he was doing it in response
to the violence that antiva was was
pushing on right-wing people that would
have these meetings show up yeah doing
like it's all clown mirror back at them
it's all crazy reham was all poorly
thought out but the idea that that makes
you a white nationalist cuz you talk
because you talk to them yeah it's so
[ __ ] stupid but it's like this is the
world we live in and everything
summarized it's like your left or right
your black/white your one or zero it's
like there's no gray area what they also
freeze you in the one moment that you
said the thing and then there's no
before after there's no growth there's
nothing it's like yeah [ __ ] out yeah
they just look for this quote trap and
just that's it I said that you said that
like not like I clarified like yeah I
took it back I revisited it like there's
a lot of things that people do when you
talk or you just you know you say things
like you say things like you don't even
know what the [ __ ] you're gonna say when
you're saying it yes and then you go up
doesn't make sense when you read
re-clarify and when you're talking a
long-form conversation and like this and
a podcast and someone wants to take a
snip it out of it and I just decided
that's who you are it's nuts it doesn't
make any sense and it's this is the
world we're living in today everybody
wants to paint everyone is toxic yeah
everyone that you want to paint so many
people I should say want to paint people
as being a problem or a negative thing
and it's like this is the Twitter world
where 20% of the people make 80% of yes
yeah so many of them are [ __ ] losers
and it's also it's such a you're giving
all of your power out to outward you're
not paying attention to yourself you're
blaming others you're trying to change
the world around you you're trying to
create a safe space through other people
yeah yeah like you know unhappy you're
gonna be in your life if you're
expecting other people to come cour to
all of your demands and 12 your stuff
they're not trying to be happy part of
it with what they're trying to do is
somehow or another score points and rack
up was you know and distract themselves
from their own life by focusing on these
external issues that they think are
critical and
important and some of them are obviously
running for president whoever's gonna be
presidents very important issue and most
of the time like 95% of time I avoid
comments but for whatever reason I just
found myself flipping through it because
I wanted to see what the people think
about Bernie yeah you can't look you
can't love it seems worse though it
seems like every time I check if I don't
check Twitter for four months and then I
check it it's like whoa is that if
things accelerated this much or people
are so angry at so many different things
and just they they paint people in such
character caricature way like a OC is a
woman who I don't think they're I don't
think I've ever seen anybody work so
people worked so hard to mischaracterize
her or paint her in a horrible light and
I'm like look she says things that I
don't agree with yeah why is everyone so
[ __ ] angry like what is this well
people were put all their thing on
things on you know those are they have
these beliefs and like definitely when I
was in my whole like you know when I was
extra angry and feeling you know you you
have this whole system around you mm-hmm
and you you know you can't hear the
other side and you have to like yes
everyone has to be a villain in that or
they they're either with you or against
you and I don't know it's just timmy is
just unhealthy I had to tap out I
stopped paying attention to a lot of
stuff and I don't know if that makes me
ignorant I just got to live a happy life
no I don't think it does make you angry
I don't think it's a an effective way to
communicate I think it's a really
piss-poor way to communicate and I think
it it fosters rage more than I mean yeah
there's something about being able to
talk to people where you don't have
social cues you don't have a movie
you're not looking at them and people
say the mean is nasty [ __ ] other and
it's insulting people and dunking on
people is more important than actual
community well its attention too so it's
you know they're maybe trying to impress
their other buddies that are on there
they're trying to get those extra little
likes right they're like the the main
point would be they want to get your
attention holy [ __ ] that got Joe Rogan's
attention that's so cool you know they
just want to feel alive or whatever and
that's you know people have their own
process I try to not take anything
personally it's like you don't know me
if you don't like me like that's weird
you don't know me you
really have that much of opinion it's
like not finding your validation you
can't find the good stuff or the bad
stuff in the comments you can't well if
you look at the comments for good things
it's just as bad as looking at for bad
things yeah I mean some people think
it's a good idea to gauge like whether
or not the conversation was effective
whether or not you could have done
something better than navigate it more
efficiently or more more entertaining
for the make it more entertaining for
the people that are listen looking for
the constructive criticism yeah they're
mean there can be some of that from some
people the problem is you're trying to
manage all this data at scale right
you're dealing with thousands and
thousands of humans that are chiming in
and a lot of them are deeply unhappy
yeah a lot of people that are commenting
on things are just really frustrated
with their lives like imagine if someone
saw or listened to you when you're like
[ __ ] man and yeah and they're like oh
that's who she exactly then you see they
see you on here laughing and being silly
yeah wait a minute [ __ ] yeah like that
doesn't make any sense that's not the
same person yeah well you're not the
same person you're not the same person
who you were six months ago
[Applause]